[Aplausos]
[Música]
45 años han pasado 45 años desde que
china y australia establecieron
relaciones diplomáticas desde entonces
amigos de visual política las cosas han
cambiado muchísimo
[Música]
en la orina
the days words
con goldman sant hilari patrones de
postura y por una serie de observaciones
ordenó por el western el servicio ahora
la demandante y la diestra jll / bocina
[Música]
a lo largo de todos estos años estos dos
países han cuajado una de las relaciones
más fructíferas controvertidas e
interesantes de todo el planeta una
relación cocinada con historias de
dinero espías acusaciones infidelidades
y muchos pero que muchos intereses
contrapuestos vamos que si en vez de
relaciones entre los países estuviéramos
hablando de relaciones entre dos
personas tendríamos aquí un
extraordinario guión para toda una
telenovela latinoamericana
pero evidentemente esto es visual
políticas y que al grano
china es hoy el mayor socio comercial de
este país sus compras suponen ni más ni
menos que un tercio de todas las
exportaciones australianas ocho veces
más que las exportaciones a eeuu fijaos
en 2015 china y australia firmaron un
acuerdo de libre comercio y hoy las
relaciones comerciales superan atentos
los ciento cincuenta y cinco mil
millones de dólares cada año
[Música]
y no sólo eso china es también un
inversor cada vez más importante en
australia un país donde por cierto una
de cada 20 personas es de origen chino
entre ellas muchos millonarios que han
decidido buscar un lugar más seguro y
con más garantías para sus patrimonios y
sus vidas las relaciones comerciales con
chinas son de tal envergadura que los
mercados financieros han considerado
desde hace mucho tiempo que el dólar
australiano es una de las mejores
opciones para apostar sobre la propia
china
por supuesto todo esto tiene
consecuencias hemos hablado de ello ya
aquí en visual política australia ha
batido todos los récords y lleva casi 30
años sin conocer lo que es una crisis
que envidia verdad pues bien en todo
este éxito el grande es pere chino como
podéis ver ha tenido mucho pero que
mucho que ver ahora ya podemos entender
perfectamente porque cuando el lowe
institute un importante think tank del
país le preguntó el pasado año los
australianos y relación era para ellos
más importantes si la relación con eeuu
o la relación con china se produjese un
empate y eso que con sus colegas
norteamericanos las relaciones son muy
pero que muy estrechas sin embargo a
pesar de todo este romance lo cierto es
que 2017 no ha sido un año precisamente
de amor entre australia y china
atentos a estas palabras de bob carr un
antiguo ministro de exteriores de
australia este año australia declaró a
china la guerra retórica las palabras
usadas por los líderes australianos son
las más ásperas desde que ambos países
establecieron relaciones diplomáticas en
1972 con la excepción de las
declaraciones tras los acontecimientos
de tiannamen el tono es más duro que el
de cualquier otro aliado de eeuu
incluido japón tal cual como lo
escucháis 2017 ha sido un año bastante
difícil para las relaciones entre estos
dos países tanto que una encuesta
realizada por el 'global times' uno de
los periódicos más populares de china
determinó que australia fue el país más
hostil hacia china durante 2017 y la
verdad es o contra anv en la presidencia
de la casa blanca son palabras mayores
y quién que tiene al lado sainz
este gran staff en decir 7 pero qué
diantres ha pasado que ha sembrado tanta
discordia entre camberra y pekín
pues bien veámoslo
[Música]
la tormenta
a decir verdad en un primer momento 2017
parecía que iba a ser un buen año para
los intereses chinos en australia las
relaciones económicas no cesaban de
crecer
trump haciendo gala de sus mejores dotes
diplomáticas le colgó el teléfono al
mismísimo primer ministro australiano
malcolm tar bolt lo que hundió aún más
su popularidad en esta zona del mundo
y el gobierno australiano incluso se
mostró partidario públicamente de que
china
sustitúyese a estados unidos como
miembro protagonista del fallido tvp el
acuerdo de libre comercio del pacífico
vamos que casi podemos decir que en
términos de telenovela el amor estaba a
punto de triunfar
[Música]
sin embargo amigos la tranquilidad no
duró mucho a mitad de año las cosas y
empezó a torcerse y de qué manera si
vamos a ver ya se habían producido
choques pero nada que no fuese habitual
el gobierno australiano en los últimos
años ha seguido una estrategia que como
decirlo consistía en tratar de
equilibrar permanentemente su posición
entre pekín y washington
en asuntos económicos guiños a pekín y
en cuestiones de seguridad y defensa
washington por supuesto ya os hemos
contado aquí en visual político que los
republicanos consideran que australia es
el mejor aliado de eeuu y no es para
menos fijaos australia es el único país
que ha intervenido en todas las grandes
guerras de eeuu y además desde hace unos
años las relaciones militares son de tal
calibre que australia se está
convirtiendo en la gran punta de lanza
del poder norteamericano en esta zona
del mundo el propio primer ministro
australiano tiene muy claro su aprecio
hacia eeuu atentos la paz y la
estabilidad de nuestra región han sido
permitidas por el liderazgo global
estadounidense aunque ese liderazgo no
hubiera sido posible sin el poder duro
de las flotas y los ejércitos su mayor
potencia proviene de los valores que
encarnan a través de todos los giros de
la historia los eeuu han defendido los
valores en los que se fundó su gran
república la libertad la democracia y el
estado
pero regresando a la cuestión china
fijaos estas palabras que acabamos de
ver fueron pronunciadas el 2 de junio de
2017 fue la primera vez que un primer
ministro australiano hablaba tan claro
en favor de washington en un discurso
por cierto cargado de advertencias a
china
pues bien tan sólo ocho días más tarde
se desataba la tormenta mediática y si
eso es final sanford inyecciones secan
estos extraños en 36 extensión varios
medios se hicieron eco de una noticia la
agencia de inteligencia australiana
estaba realizando serias advertencias
sobre las intenciones del gobierno chino
de influir en la política australiana
mediante diferentes medios entre ellos
la compra de políticos periodistas y
científicos o la vigilancia y la
intimidación de ciudadanos
pertenecientes a la propia comunidad
china en australia el escándalo estaba
servido
de repente aparecieron noticias sobre la
colaboración de universidades y
científicos australianos con
contratistas militares chinos o de
antiguos políticos como por ejemplo el
ex ministro de comercio andrew rock que
ahora trabajan para empresas controladas
por el gobierno chino a cambio de
jugosos salarios de cientos de miles de
dólares veréis los recelos y miedos de
los servicios de seguridad australianos
ante el espionaje chino no son algo
nuevo y los diferentes gobiernos
australianos llevan años bloqueando
algunas operaciones corporativas de
empresas chinas y también han prohibido
que empresas como huawei puedan
participar en el despliegue de la red
nacional de banda ancha sin embargo la
polémica nunca antes había llegado tan
lejos los informes de los medios de
comunicación han sugerido que el partido
comunista chino ha estado trabajando
para interferir de forma encubierta con
nuestros medios de comunicación nuestras
universidades e incluso con las
decisiones de los representantes electos
aquí mismo en este edificio en el
parlamento
el 12 de diciembre de 2017 sam dastyar y
senador del partido laborista y una de
las figuras políticas más prometedoras
del país se vio obligado a dimitir por
sus vínculos con china al ser statement
dream firework strain aumentar o manjar
en la ley de sede
with nothing to cut 2 brian ching / tipo
entre otras cosas se le acusa de recibir
dinero a cambio de realizar discursos en
favor de los intereses del gobierno
chino e incluso de haber alertado a un
empresario chino vinculado al partido
comunista de que podía estar siendo
investigado por las agencias de
inteligencia y de que su teléfono podía
estar intervenido científicos que
colaboran con contratistas militares
chinos infiltración en los campus
universitarios pagos a periodistas
políticos comprados las acusaciones se
han venido sucediendo de forma constante
desde el mes de julio el gobierno
australiano lo está denunciando
públicamente y ha comenzado ya a
modificar la legislación sobre espionaje
traición inmigración y también
financiación de los partidos políticos y
todo apunta amigos a que esto es sólo el
principio chris nelson
es proyectos incluyen sectores director
against las consecuencias de éste
y enfriamiento en las relaciones
políticas se está haciendo ver por
ejemplo en política exterior en 2017 se
ha notado como nunca antes el giro de
australia en favor de eeuu ahora bien no
penséis que esta postura es unánime
entre la clase política para nada el
gobierno no parece entender la
importancia económica de la relación con
china o las cuestiones estratégicas
involucradas estamos poniendo toda
nuestra fe en nuestra relación con china
a través de la lente de la política
exterior de los eeuu y amigos sabéis que
no es para menos
por un lado muchos críticos afirman que
realmente no hay tantas pruebas de toda
esa injerencia china que está
denunciando el gobierno hay quien
incluso afirma que todo esto es una
operación política alimentada por
washington
por otro lado romper con china o al
menos ser tan contundente con el
gobierno de pekín no es algo
precisamente fácil para australia porque
atentos
[Música]
china se defiende
en toda esta crisis política china ha
sido muy contundente por supuesto ha
negado tajantemente todas las
acusaciones e incluso ha dicho que toda
esta campaña se basa en prejuicios
raciales y en una clara paranoia
antichina una paranoia que han
denunciado está traduciéndose en una
clara hostilidad hacia la comunidad
china la diplomacia china alerta a los
estudiantes en australia a permanecer
alerta por riesgos en la seguridad tras
una avalancha de ataques la verdad es
que más allá de unos cuantos carteles en
alguna que otra universidad no parece
que haya evidencia de este supuesto
peligro pero si algo es evidente es que
esta denuncia por un lado muestra cómo
están las cosas y por otro está claro no
es buena publicidad
veréis los estudiantes chinos suponen 4
de cada 10 estudiantes extranjeros en
las universidades australianas y cada
año se gastan atentos 18 mil millones de
dólares en el país si así es podemos
estar ante una primera advertencia del
gobierno chino dejando claro que está
dispuesto a jugar las cartas económicas
como medida de presión algo que por
cierto ha utilizado ya recientemente con
corea del sur y con taiwán
[Música]
pero no solo hablamos de los estudiantes
sino también de los turistas o los
inversores por ejemplo en los últimos
años el sector del lujo está
experimentando todo un boom económico en
australia
sabéis porque atentos los estudiantes
turistas y residentes chinos en
australia son responsables de hasta dos
tercios de las ventas al pormenor del
lujo en sydney melbourne otro ejemplo
las inversiones directas de china en
australia se han multiplicado no por
diez ni por veinte sino por treinta y
dos en apenas nueve años por treinta y
dos así que como veis un frenazo en todo
este proceso podría traducirse en mucho
pero que mucho dolor para la economía
australiana en fin amigos así están las
cosas de momento el gobierno australiano
se mantiene fiel a su estrecha relación
con washington estados unidos parece
haber asegurado una alianza
imprescindible para sus intereses en
esta zona del mundo y también por cierto
para su industria militar en los últimos
años
australia se ha convertido en uno de sus
mejores clientes
en la próxima década espera gastarse más
de 100 mil millones de dólares
en renovar sus fuerzas armadas y aquí
los contratistas norteamericanos parten
con ventaja
[Música]
y sin embargo por otro lado no son pocos
y con esto me refiero a políticos
empresarios y ciudadanos quienes piden
que australia se mantenga neutral y
proteja su seguridad nacional sin
necesidad de realizar tantas acusaciones
públicas cómo terminará esta historia
estará en riesgo una de las relaciones
más fructíferas de los últimos años sólo
el tiempo nos lo podrá contar pero ahora
turno para ti hacia dónde crees que debe
girar la política australiana déjanos tu
respuesta en los comentarios y también
en esta encuesta si este vídeo te ha
resultado interesante
no olvides darle al botón de like y por
supuesto tampoco de suscribirte a visual
política un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]